bonjour c'est pas mal mais ça pourrait
être un petit peu mieux
qui parmi vous a déjà pénétré dans une
boulangerie française favorite à vous
mettre debout s'il vous plaît et à
connecter avec ce moment où votre
boulangère vous dit bonjour en plus elle
a un talent particulier cette boulangère
parfois pour se rappeler de votre nom ah
bonjour thérèse alors ses rhumatismes
aujourd'hui mon prénom et benoît vous
allez me dire bonjour avec la même joie
de vivre que votre boulangère vous dit
bonjour vous êtes prêts 1 2 3
c'est bien merci beaucoup on peut
s'asseoir nos boulangère et nos
boulangeries françaises
lorsqu'il fait froid dehors le matin et
qu'on sent la chaleur des boulangeries
lorsque les effluves de bain tout juste
sorti du four caresse nos narines
ce pain qui craquent sous la main qui
croque sous la dent c'est une
chorégraphie d'expérience client une
poésie à la française du commerce et
bien sûr le sourire de la boulangère se
aujourd'hui j'aimerais partager avec
vous
trois idées sur ce sourire de la
boulangère tout d'abord à quel point ce
sourire est puissant à quel point il se
diffuse dans le quartier dans la ville
dans le territoire de cette boulangère
ensuite à quel point ce sourire est
rentable et productif et compétitif et
enfin avec la vague digital depuis 20
ans à kehl à quel point il est vital
aujourd'hui ce sourire de la boulangère
lorsque j'arrive au chili à 23 en tant
que coopérant français les boulangères
me disais oh lamia mort comme on reste à
ce qui signifie bonjour l'amour comment
ça va skins façon curieuse d'introduire
lire bonjour mais chacun à sa façon
chaque pour rendre le client unique car
comment se sont-ils ce petit garçon
captées par l'objectif de robert
doisneau en 1953 qu'est-ce qu'ils
respirent qu'on se sente il que lui a
dit la boulangère pour ils sont si fiers
lui at elle dit coût mais tu grandis
voix ou encore tu fais le commission
c'est bien ça ce petit garçon va
diffuser cette bonne humeur cette
énergie en rentrant chez lui dans son
quartier il ce sens unique
il se sent écouté
alors bien sûr ces valeurs là sont
essentielles cette notion de l' écoute
de l'autre de la relation à l'autre
cette ville d'un mètre quarante du
commerce et pourtant depuis vingt ans la
neuropsychologie à neurosciences nous
apporter plusieurs découvertes qui qui
change la donne qui en tout cas nous
force à nous rendre compte que nous
avons un pouvoir illimité sur les autres
trois enseignements selon
appartenez-vous le premier les neurones
miroirs si je me mets à bâiller je vais
vous collez le bâillement le bâillement
n'est ce pas si je fais la tête
vous ferez la tête est si je souris vous
allez sourire et si nous faisions un un
scanner de mon cerveau a dû votre un irm
à bien les zones de mon cerveau qui
s'active lorsque je souris s'activerait
également dans le vôtre enseignement
numéro un
la boulangère est responsable non
seulement le son sourire mais également
du sourire de sa clientèle son quartier
sa ville
même si l à 380 clients par jour même si
comme après la messe en bretagne sur le
plateau l'église de seine-et-marne
robineau on n'avait que entière et bien
on garde le sourire et on diffuse bonne
humeur dans son environnement
le seconde découverte c'est d'ailleurs
vannes et cessons les fuseaux de
neurones je me convertis à ce à quoi je
pense si je pense que je vais jouer
alors j'ai raison si je pense que je
vais réussir j'ai également raison les
fuseaux de neurones si la boulangère
pense qu'elle peut réussir à faire du +
30% alors elle va réussir cette source
passe le 14 février 2014 à donetsk en
ukraine
un jeune garçon de clermont ferrand
renaud lavillénie voit une barre qui est
perché à 6 mètres 16 depuis 21 ans
personne n'a pas passé les six mètres 15
de ce groupe k pensez vous que renault
se dit zut
cette barre elle est un petit peu trop
haute ou encore se dit gilles je vais le
passer
il pense à ces vins pas de foule et il
pense à l'impact de la perche au moment
de franchir la barre ils vont toutes
être à l'hymne national la marseillaise
qu'il doit ressentir
peut-être même que dans les semaines qui
ont précédé cet événement il pensait il
se voyait en train de réussir
ce qui est sûr c'est que les circuits
neuronaux qu'il mettait en marche
lorsqu'il pensait à sa réussite sont les
mêmes qu'il va avoir besoin lorsqu'il va
sauter effectivement je me convertis à
ce à quoi je pense le simple fait de
penser que je vais réussir et déjà un
premier pas pour réussir notre
boulangère si elle veut réussir à
étendre son affaire à vendre davantage à
rendre les gens plus heureux
elles peuvent le proposer et enfin j'ai
eu le privilège depuis six ans avec
l'équipe fabuleuse coach dans le monde
entier de coacher des commerçants des
boulangères des pharmaciens des patrons
aux grands réseaux des caissières dans
l'intimité du coaching et beaucoup m'ont
dit benoît moi je suis timide aux
courbes benoît je suis nul en maths
je ne comprends rien aux chiffres pensez
vous qu'une femme de 48 ans qui est
perçu d'être timide ou père fait d'être
nulle en maths peut changer pensez vous
que si on se propose on peut dépasser
ces limitations la neuroplasticité dit
que oui nous pouvons à tout âge quel que
soit notre condition notre âge continuer
à apprendre continuer à dépasser nos
peurs à dépasser nos craintes et dont le
commerce
par ailleurs les chiffres de maîtriser
un chiffre ne faisait que si j'ai vendu
20 mille euros et j'ai mille tickets
alors que ja ticket moyen de 20 euros
plus de la moitié des gens que je
rencontre ne sont pas très à l'aise avec
ça donc trois enseignements les neurones
miroirs les fuseaux et la
neuroplasticité
et cette boulangère est là une question
formidable pour continuer la relation
bonjour qu'est ce que je vous sers à une
baguette il vous plait oui et avec ceci
dans dix ans ceci la voix mondine octane
et elle continue à proposer ce que l'on
dit non merci
et cette question parfois nous irrite
n'est ce pas dans le commerce qu'on nous
propose des choses mais avait quelques
raisons elle nous irrite pas pourquoi
park a réussi à créer une relation ce
sourire ouvre une relation uvre ouvre
une possibilité de vente
l'histoire que je vais vous raconter se
passe il y a une dizaine d'années à
l'époque je pilote un réseau de 8000
magasins et l'histoire que je vous
racontais ma perturbé m'a fait
énormément réfléchir elle se passe dans
un réseau de qui vend des chaînes hi fi
haut de gamme design les meilleurs du
marché aux états unis
cette enseigne remet cinq cartes
american express gold sans plafond à
cinq clients mystères en leur disant
vous pouvez vous rendre dans cinq de nos
magasins et acheter l'ensemble du
magasin tout à une condition que le
vendeur vous le propose de telle manière
que si le vendeur l'un après l'autre
vous propose l'ensemble des articles et
bien vous dirai juste
oui merci à votre avis combien des cinq
clients mystères ont pu acheter
l'ensemble du magasin
aucun aucun
en plus nous paraît sont tous d'accord
pour le dire de manière spontanée n'est
ce pas et quand je dis que cette
histoire m'a perturbé c'est que je suis
voilà si j'étais le patron de ces cinq
personnes qu'est-ce que je leur dirai
pas ce facile durée légale pour revendre
mais ça on l'a déjà fait l époque je
n'avais pas de réponse
probablement que il a manqué une
relation problement qu'il a manqué comme
ce petit garçon de robert doisneau à
s'intéresser à l'autre par exemple en
disant voilà c'est pour quels usages
pour permettre par exemple aux clients
de diaba écouteurs j'ai une passion dans
la vie c wagner
tous les ans les cons épouse droit byron
au festival de wagner en allemagne et je
mettrai ce qu'il faut pour avoir la
meilleure acoustique au monde afin de
pouvoir écouter wagner dans mon salon
qu'est ce qui change maintenant échange
je connais leurs échanges que je vais
lorsque je lui proposer les meilleures
enceintes les meilleurs les meilleurs
accessoires ce sera pour lui faire
plaisir et lui dira merci la relation
avec l'autre dans les dernières années
on a eu aussi cette cette vague du
digital cette vague du vendeur augmenté
du vendeur connectés qui parmi vous a
déjà acheté sur internet
alors que devient trop boulangère dans
cet environnement là et si jamais votre
boulangère est terriblement présent
terriblement actuel terriblement
innovantes justement parce sourire par
cette présence parce qu'aujourd'hui nos
vendeurs sont capables d'être muni de
tablettes d'être connecté aux stocks
connectés alex à l'historique client est
ce que cette connexion va nous
déconnecter de notre client au contraire
va-t-elle générer une expérience client
entre encore plus magnifique parce que
par exemple je vais me souvenir de son
expérience de son historique de ventes
connecté ou déconnecté augmentent et où
vivent la bulle avec l'autre
que disent les études disent que 84% des
français estiment que dans les magasins
gagne manque de personnalisation de la
relation client on ne s'intéresse pas
suffisamment à l'autre on ne connaît
plus on son nom 70% estiment en plus que
wanda il manque d'expertisé oui soit le
pain aussi céréales le pain sans gluten
que ce soit en dans la jardinerie dans
l'électronique dans la cuisine est ce
que mon vendeur vraiment on sait plus
que moi qui maintenant sur internet suc
et parle de m'informer et enfin 2
français sur 3 nous disent qu'ils aiment
échanger avec le vendeur cette bulle
elle est moderne
on en a besoin et nous clients allons
continuer à nous rendre les magasins
condition qu' on a une bonne raison pour
le faire ce qui est en jeu c'est
vraiment la boulangère attitude la
boulangère attitude c'est cette façon
n'est pas ses mots commerçante qui aussi
cette approche pour un pour un
professeur pour un médecin pour 1
retraité pour nous parents comme pour
nos voisins de pouvoir utiliser nos
neurones miroirs pouvoir utiliser cette
psychologie positive tenait j'aimerais
partager avec vous probablement une des
plus belles expériences clients que j'ai
vécu dans ma vie elle se passe au jeudi
23 octobre 2003 dit cadre européen d'une
multinationale américaine ont leur
convention euros annuels à barcelone le
soir ils descendent dîner sur le port de
barcelone et en rentrant à 23h30 cherche
un taxi
avec tellement chance que justement taxi
arrive avec les couleurs typiques noir
et jaune de barcelone je m'assois sur le
siège arrière droit de telle manière que
je peux voir le chauffeur en oblique
j'observe qu'il a le visage boursouflé
horrible on dirait les franz mann jeudi
pour briser la glace non alors vous
travaillez en sursis oui monsieur mais
pour moi c'est un problème parce que je
suis un homme heureux et en plus
aujourd'hui c'était le plus beau jour de
ma vie parce qu'aujourd'hui
alicia mais adado vaisseau alicia la
donne un baiser
il nous raconte comment depuis trente
ans il aime passionnément une femme il
lui écrit des dizaines de poèmes d'amour
tous plus beaux les uns que les autres
d'ailleurs près du lait de vitesse il ya
un recueil qui s'appelle poèmes as des
verdots par alicia et ce matin il a
déclamé un poème en alexandrins qui a
tellement émue alicia qu'elle le donne
un baiser pendant que nous avançons vers
l'hôtel
il nous déclare ce poème qui le matin
même le value ce baiser à quand il
restait quelques centaines de mètres
avant d'arriver nos digues en plus un
laboratoire pharmaceutique l'a appelé il
ya quelques jours afin de lui proposer
de participer à un programme pilote pour
un médicament qui peut être allait
guérir son infirmité cette course de
taxi a eu un coût de 17 euros qu'elle en
fut la valeur qu'est ce qui a apporté ce
qu'est ce qui doit se passer pour qu'une
personne ose la relation aux donne un
petit peu de lui-même
votre relation cette transaction
commerciale lui aussi à la baule
gratitude lieu c comprend que je suis
responsable de ce qui m'arrive ce ne
sont pas les politiques
ce n'est pas la météo qui fait que ça et
bien qu'elle aille mal je suis
responsable ce qui m'arrive nous sommes
chaque matin chaque soir de décider mon
attitude dans la bulle avec l'autre dans
la bulle du commerce dans la bulle de
l'éducation dans la bulle entre voisins
la bulle parents enfants seriez vous
intéressé à adopter cette boulangère
attitude
cette attitude de la psychologie
positive cette attitude où on se rend
responsable de ce qui nous arrive cette
psychologie où on peut continuer à
prendre continue à s'améliorer continuer
à gagner plus pour terminer j'aimerais
partager avec vous une des plus belles
chansons de la chanson française
d'ailleurs j'aimerais vous faire
avec moi elle se perd dans une
boulangerie et c'est une autre histoire
d'amour d'une autre rencontre
c'est une autre expérience client une
expérience où le client lui aussi de son
unique et on souhaite vous allez
tous les matins il à rejeter son petit
pain au chocolat la la la la
la boulangère lui souriait il ne la
regardait pas dans la lah
merci beaucoup